Good morning John. It is morning, which it usually is not when I make... when I say that out loud.
I'm going to take you through a day in the life of me. I just did all my morning baby stuff
and now I'm coming up to the office. I don't have anything on my calendar until around eleven, so until then arrives,
I'm working on a song, which I haven't done in a while.
I was gonna try to do it as a Song Wednesday, but [strums chord] it's just not happenin'.
All right, songwriting over. I did put it on my Tumblr; it still has some problems, but if you want to listen to it
it's there. Now it's time to choose which Pizzamas shirt I'm gonna put on. I chose this drippy pizza.
Time to go make s—
I forgot my computer! Everyone at work will be shocked, shocked! when I am late for the first meeting of the day,
which I am, at the DFTBA warehouse. We're having our staff meeting, there's a pretty snowy mountain out there.
That's nice
Dftba.com figures out how to make cool stuff for online creators and also how to get that stuff to people who want it. Basically, in this
meeting we had a bunch of cool ideas for cool things to make and then we talked about how the things that we are currently
making are doing. Everyone is very excited about Pizzamas. This is Rachel, she designs the socks, too.
Hello.
You can tell by her shirt
My everything.
[Several people laugh]
This is just a frickin' great 2017 license plate right there.
[Singing:] Work!
Candy corn flavored M&Ms?!
Eeeew...
That's not good. They're the—SO bad. Tastes like...
...you, like... "I have no strong opinions on M&M's"?
This was a mistake! I gotta go to a staff meeting.
I beat you.
You did!
Upstairs at our main office
we have the events team, mostly VidCon,
but also PodCon; this staff meeting was gathering to talk about the new space the Anaheim Convention Center has,
some PodCon marketing ideas so we can sell more tickets, and the trip that two people took to see how BlizzCon uses the
Convention Center in Anaheim so we can steal ideas from BlizzCon. It was about now that I realized that I had no scheduled time for lunch;
luckily, that meeting ended soon, so I went and got a burrito.
I mean...
Yes!!
They just painted this on this building, and as they were doing it, I noticed...
Different spacing on the sides! Oh god, it's gonna be there forever.
Glumpkins
[Singing:] Goin' down to the studi—oh my god, it's cold down here. I always forget. I need
wardrobe
my shirts
I really enjoy shooting SciShow and Crashcourse, even if it is...
pretty draining? The scripts are always
really good these days, our writing staff is
legitimately one of the best in popular science writing, in my opinion. We shot a bunch of scripts including one about animals we thought
were extinct but weren't, uh, for SciShow, and one about why gratitude is so good for people for SciShow Psych.
Which is our new psychology channel.
Now I'm going to How to Adult. [Weird voice:] How to Adult! How to Adult is one of our less well-known
channels. This video that we were making today was on how to create and send good
thank-you cards. That one, unsurprisingly, will come out around Thanksgiving. Alright I'm done shooting,
it's 3:26. So I have a half an hour before—big staff meeting!—during which I can...
maybe answer emails? I don't know; we'll find out.
Writing good emails is a... is a learned skill. Some people are very good at it.
This is a good email somebody sent me. Bad... bad news email for me,
but it was done really well. Good job, person! Pocky! All the flavors!
There's still a chair, still a chair!
And then we had our big all-staff meeting, which we only do once a month. Here, the VidCon, DFTBA, and Complexly staffs all get
together to keep each other up to date on the big picture of what's happening at each company.
I feel like these staff meetings could be super boring,
but, actually, they're very entertaining, and I find them to be one of my favorite times of the day,
which is, I feel like not usually how staff meetings go. [Burp] And now I go home! I just finished my burrito.
[Weird voice:] Gotta put a baby to bed!
Baby is in bed, I had dinner, back up to my office to... (take a phone call, and) edit a video!!
So that's usually roughly
how my days go, lots of meetings, lots of shooting, uh, and some
creative process, eh, thrown and usually they don't end up with me editing a video at 10 o'clock at night,
but it's Pizzamas, and I'm not complaining. John I honestly can't wait to see what you come up with tomorrow.
It's so fun to have, like, some creative pressure. I mean it's hard, but it's fun.
I love Pizzamas. And I'll see what you got for me tomorrow.